our team is the elite of the elite the  heart soul of this very being issued  we protect when no one wants to protect  and we go above and beyond as more than  this job than just swimming  Victoria leads the new owner the club  sucks murder all this started once leads  took over I thought we were lifeguards  everything that you guys were talking  about sounds like a really entertaining  but far-fetched TV show is running solo  you see it to be some Baywatch  [ __ ]  you go and buy night vision  you turn the canals into the goddamn X  Games yeah that's cuz we were in  lifeguard pursuit  there's no [ __ ] such thing as  lifeguard pursuit even if you were  police what you did would still be  totally illegal okay well I mean it's  good thing we're not police  you